[Music]
thanks for coming welcome to working
with work manager session my name is
Samira Kataria I'm a software engineer
at Google hi my name is Rahul Ravi Kumar
I'm also a software engineer in Google
and we both work on Android architecture
components particularly work manager let
me grab my all right so what are we
going to talk about today when I give
you a state of the union about work
manager it was released at Google i/o I
want to give you an abbreviated guide to
work managers so for those of you
haven't used work manager before we want
to go over some of the basic api's and
we're gonna spend the most of the time
talking about work manager the questions
you've asked things that have been
frequently misunderstood and also the
new changes that we've made since i/o so
let's start with the State of the Union
there have been 11 releases of work
manager since Google i/o and these are
alpha releases today was the one was the
11th one and beta is coming soon so
those of you who watched the keynote
yesterday may have heard that beta is
coming this month this was news to us
too but it's coming this month we were
very close but I guess we're doing at
this month now so we want to give you an
abbreviated guide to work manager and
what is it for those of you who are just
completely new to this it's a library
for managing deferrable background work
it wraps job scheduler and alarmmanager
broadcast receivers it's backwards
compatible to api 14 and those of you
who've used job scheduler will find many
of the concepts very familiar so let's
talk about work you've got got a unit of
background work and we'll talk a little
bit more about how we create it and how
we in queue it later but you've got it
and how does work manager execute this
work this is a graph that might help you
while your process is up and running
we'll feed it to this executor that we
have that does the work it could be a
thread pool you can customize this thing
but your process may be killed and work
manager is
guaranteed to do work it may defer it
but it will do that work when the
constraints for that work are met so we
also include in the background so if
your API 23 plus we use job scheduler
and before that we use an alarm manager
and broadcast receiver implementation so
whenever the signals are met let's say
that you've put in some work for a two
hour time delay when you're when you
have network when all of that well all
those conditions are met it'll still go
to the same executor all right let's do
a quick API walkthrough for those who
have not seen the API so the fundamental
unit of work in work manager is a worker
here I'm defining a calculation worker
it extends the worker type so now the
only thing that you need to do when you
define a new worker is to extend do work
and do work return the result here I'm
returning a success you can also return
a retry or a fail I'm doing some
expensive calculation or background
thread so you don't have to worry about
threading here because work manager is
guaranteed to schedule your work on a
background thread and here I'm returning
a result of success synchronously so
that's it I'm pretty much good to go so
now you've defined a worker how do you
actually make that work run so for that
you need to NQ a work request so there
are two types of work requests once a
one time and the other one is a periodic
work request here I'm using a one time
work request builder and I'm asking I'm
building it with the calculation worker
that I just defined in the previous
slide so I'm setting an initial delay
and this is a timing based constraint
and this this tells work manager to only
run the work after two hours have passed
since the point when queue I'm also
setting another constraint which is the
charging constraint
this tells work manager that this work
is only eligible to run when the device
is actually connected to are charging
when the device is actually charging I
add a tag I'll talk about tags in more
detail but and I'm finally calling that
build now all I need to do is to call
Karen stones and enqueue the work and
that's it now you the work is scheduled
so now you've scheduled your work you've
defined a bunch of constraints
and it's hard to keep track of and if
you want to keep track of what state
your work is in then you want to KITT
call get working for by ID live data and
this returns a live data of a list of
working live data of a work info and so
working for is the type that determines
the state of your work and live data
here is a life cycle of air observable
so once you attach it to a life cycle
owner and you define an observer you can
observe the state transitions of the
vault request so it will go something
like once the country wants you in cue
the work it will go into in queue once
the constraints are met it'll go into a
running and then finally because you
return success it's going to the
succeeded state so remember that tag
that we added when we built the one time
work request you can also get work infos
by tag live data and tag is something
that you associate with associate with a
work request and they can be one too
many so you can associate the same tag
to multiple work requests and here I'm
calling get work infos by tag live data
it runs a live data again notice how it
returns a list of work info and not a
single work info and again I can do the
same things that I did in the previous
sites like so one of the coolest
features of work manager is the ability
to chain work so that helps you define
an acyclic graph of work and here I'm
asking work manager to begin with a B
and C and here a B and C are work
requests and I'm saying that DNA are
only eligible to run once all a B and C
are done and when I say when I use the
begin with API I'm asking work manager
to run a B and C potentially in parallel
whether they actually run in parallel
are is determined by the capabilities of
the device and the size of your thread
pool and finally I'm calling at then on
F G and H again that now F G and H will
only run once all the preceding works
are done finally don't forget to call in
queue that's when all the magic happens
so so now you call them queue now you
might be wondering what begin what
returns begin with returns so begin with
actually returns an instance of work
continuation and a work continuation is
a node inner acyclic graph
and this lends to a very fluent API so
every time you call begin with it
returns a new continuation and every
time you call that then it returns a new
instance of another continuation finally
don't forget to call thank you the one
important thing that you need to
remember is when you chain work the
outputs of parent are the outputs of the
parent work requests become inputs to
your descending work request or your
children this helps you managed it and
send state from parent work to the
descendant work and so now finally
there's work manager also exposes the
ape the API is to cancel work so for
some reason if you want to do that you
can cancel work by ID and every work
request has a unique ID so here we're
canceling work by that ID and you can
also cancel all work by tag so those are
the two api's and that's it and I want
to point out that all the things we've
all the APS we've been showing are for
alpha 11 so that you may notice some
slight changes for those of you who have
been using this API before but
everything is live today so let's talk a
little bit about how you can get the
most out of work manager and these also
include questions like how do I do a
certain type of task why does this work
this way a certain way and the biggest
one that we get a question about is
threading
how does threading work in work manager
so we talked about a about a work
request Rahul just mention that and you
in cue it what happens to it then so we
have an internal tab we call it an
internal task executor you can think of
it as a single threaded executor and the
in queue goes to that which stores it in
a local database so every app that uses
work manager has a work manager database
this is the source of truth this is
where we keep track of the state of your
work your inputs and outputs everything
with the dependency chains everything
goes in this database so after it's been
in queued some time later your
constraints are met and the OS tells you
that if you have no constraints it's
eligible to run it right away if there
are constraints the OS will tell you oh
you have network you are charging right
now whatever it is same task executor
uses a worker factory to create a worker
worker Factory is exactly what it is
it's a factory for workers and you can
make your own you can customize and do
things with that we'll talk more about
that later after the workers been
created we execute it on an executor and
this is also a thing that you can
actually customize we'll talk more about
that later as well
but what if you don't want to execute
something on that executor we give you a
default one you could specify your own
but what if you're using rx Java what if
you're using co-routines what if you
have your own bespoke solution that you
want to use to run things in the
background this was a request that came
up quite a lot when we first released
work manager so to do this we want to
provide you a an API to let you do work
on your own and just tell us when it's
done so you want to signal async or
completion to us and for that we use a
class called listenable future those of
you who use guava will be very familiar
with this but we split it out and the
guava team has helped us with this so
everybody's collaboratively worked on
splitting this out to its own
lightweight artifact so you don't need a
full guava dependency for this it's
literally one one or two classes now and
it's a future that can have one or more
listeners and those listeners can be
invoked on a specified executor that's
all it is it's very simple
so using this little future we made a
class called listenable worker which
only has one method that you need to
override it's called start work will
call start work on the main thread for
you you give us back a list of all
future you do whatever work you want on
whatever thread you want and when you're
done just set the result on the future
and we'll be able to listen for it and
we'll be able to react to it
so the actual threading model in work
manager is after your constraints are
met it goes to the test executor which
uses the worker Factory to create a list
of all worker we call start work on it
and we also attach a listener so we can
listen to whenever you're done what this
means is that the worker class which is
still around is a simple listenable
worker so we've got the do work method
that we talked about we override the
start work for you we create a future
on that background executor that I
talked about the one we provide by
default we execute the work and we of
course return the future so now we have
two classes worker and listenable worker
what's the differences between them
workers we consider those a simple class
for most use cases we think that
sufficient is a class that runs
synchronously and on a pre-specified
background thread list of all worker
runs asynchronously on us unspecified
background thread so worker do work is a
synchronous API you're expected to
finish what you're doing there if you're
trying to create a list of all worker
you may need to return a list of all
future which is an interface if you have
access to guava you have access to many
tens of list of all futures if you don't
have access to guava or don't want to
add the dependency resolvable future is
a lightweight implementation that we
provide in Android X concurrent
concurrent futures so you can use that
so let's look at an example one of the
things that a lot of people are trying
and doing incorrectly with workers is
that they're trying to get locations and
we're gonna specifically use the fused
location provider clients so if you
listen to the cotton suspenders talk
yesterday they also use this it's a GM s
core API to asynchronously get your
location remember that a worker class is
synchronous so if you attach a callback
and later get informed about it but
returns success you your work is already
completed it's not gonna work the way
you think it is so first thing we do
here we're using a list of all worker is
we create a resolvable futures so this
is the future that will return and do
all our bookkeeping on in the start work
method we'll check to see if we have
permissions if we don't we'll set of
tail here on the future otherwise what
we'll do is we'll get that fuse location
providers last location this is kind of
like a future in GMS core or Google Play
services world and we'll call this get
location method which I'll go into and
then we return the future so that's sort
of the high level start work in the low
K
get location method will use that task
and will add a listener to it if the
task is successful we'll pass that
location back with a success status
otherwise we'll set an exception on the
future so that's it we've basically
addressed like the the three cases where
we want to have a successful or an
unsuccessful task or if we don't have
permissions and work manager we'll
attach that listener
it'll listen to the success or failure
of their task and do the bookkeeping as
necessary all right let's talk about
operations no remember soonish mentioned
that work manager uses a database as a
source of truth so any any time you end
you or you cancel work we have to do
some bookkeeping and we have to make
sure we keep track of what your
intention to there so these involve
writes to a database and because they're
there are rights to our database we have
to do them on a background thread
so as a result they're asynchronous what
if you actually wanted to do something
after the end queue happened or the
cancel happen so you want to make sure
that those operations completed before
you want to do some more stuff so for
that we've introduced a new API so now
in queue and cancel actually return a
new type called operation operation is a
very simple interface it has two methods
so it has a get state API which returns
a live data of an operation dot state if
you attach an observer to this live data
you will see that the operation
transitions from in progress to a
successful or failure you can also call
get result and this returns the familiar
listenable feature type and remember
that this API will only return the
terminal state of the operation it won't
give you the intermediate state so if
you're attaching a listener you will
only ever get a success or failed and
with the exceptions and Turing you why
the failure happened another question a
lot of people have is when is work
stopped what happens when you stop work
on behalf of work manager yeah all right
so
there's three cases when work is stopped
the first day is very simple your
constraints are no longer met so you
said for example that I need a network
to do this upload task but your network
got lost so we will stop your work at
that point a second case is that they
always preempted your work for some
reason for example you exceeded the
10-minute time limit that the OS gives
you to do your work or the device
decided to go into doze mode for battery
savings or something like that and the
third reason is that you just cancelled
your work somewhere else in your app how
do we stop work there's a method
listenable worker on stopped we call
this method when we stop so just
override this and you get your cancel
your stop signal right there we also
cancel that future that we talked about
so you can also just add your own
listener and look for that so this is
you're one of them in one of these two
things happens for you whichever one
you're looking at this is your signal to
be a good citizen and clean up because
after this is called the process may be
killed by the OS
so if always woke up your apps process
just to run this work it could actually
kill it when it decides that the work
should stop and if you happen to return
something after this signal say you
return to success we ignore it because
as far as we're concerned your work has
been stopped whatever you're doing is no
longer necessary to be done you can also
pull for stoppages in your workers so
you can also call the is stopped method
and that'll fine that'll tell you
whether you've been signaled for
stopping so let's look at how you can be
a good citizen and clean up so let's say
your example in this example we're
parsing a file asynchronously let's say
it's a huge file so you're doing it in a
worker and you've got that familiar
resolvable future thing that I showed
you earlier you've also got this input
stream so you're reading a file right so
in start work you say parse file this is
doing something asynchronously and you
return the future
here's parse file so you've got some
executor or whatever I call routine it
doesn't matter it you're asynchronously
doing that runnable that follows so the
first thing you might be doing is you're
opening a file you're reading each byte
out of the file doing some
with that bite and then when you're done
you set a success because you're done
and then you have the necessary try
catch finally after that so that you can
clean up after yourself so how do we
handle when your work gets stopped while
this is executing so like I said we
override Aeon stop method let's say that
we want to just finish what we're doing
we could easily just close that input
file stream okay so what happens now
you've done that let's go back to the
code well if you're in the middle of
that read loop and you close a file it
throws an exception right you next time
you try to read something well
fortunately you're already handling that
exception right there so it looks like
you're good right you you're you're done
or are you there's one more case that
you forgot about here which is that what
if the on stop happens before you even
open the file so now you're no longer
looking for that stop thing because you
never got that signal you'll read that
file because it opened after you tried
to close it which it didn't do anything
for so you'll do all of this work and
how you fix it is use that is stop
method so basically while you're in that
loop you can always just make sure that
you're looking for stoppages so this is
a good example of how you would honor
the OSS signal to you or work managers
signal to you that you should stop and
be a good citizen right so every time
you in queue a method or in every time
you in queue work request the work
request goes through several state
transitions and I'll talk about how they
look so let's look at life of a one-time
work request so when you in queue a new
work request it can end up in one of two
states it can be blocked if it's blocked
on another work request if you know
given it's a chain work or it can be in
queued once the constraints are met it
goes into running and this is the point
at which the worker is being actively
executed once depending on the result
that you returned on how you signal work
completion will take it to one of the
terminal states so if the worker returns
success then it's a terminate we will
terminate it with a succeeded state if
the worker returns a failure then we
will mark it as a failure and that
the terminal state at any point in time
while the worker was in a nonterminating
state if you call canceled then it is
sorry if you actually retry then we will
apply the back off policy and then we
will retry so the worker will go back to
the include State at any point in time
if you have a non terminating State and
you call cancel it will end up in
cancelled so this is what a life of a
one-time work request looks like now
let's look at periodic work periodic
work is almost the same because periodic
work can't be chained
there's no block state so it always ends
up in the end cute state once the
constraints are met it'll go into
running so whether whether you succeed
or you retry it will go back to the end
cute state now this might seem confusing
if you succeed then the work really
isn't done because it's a periodic work
we'll just wait for the next interval if
you fail and you ask us to retry then
we'll apply the appropriate back off
policy and then we'll increment the run
attempt account so we will tell you that
this is the second time that you're
trying to run it for that last period
and if you mark your work as failed then
we'll transition it to the failed state
at that point your periodic work won't
run again and again any time your work
is in a non terminal state and if you
ask us to cancel it we will mark it
cancelled so let's apply those rules to
how life of a chain of work looks like
so here is the parent of all workers so
when is when you include this chain of
work only is in the in queued state and
all descendants of a are actually
blocked now right so let's assume is
constraints are met and it goes into rot
running State once is done let's assume
it's exceeded so it unlocks B and C now
so B and C now become one Q and then
they go into running and for the sake of
the argument let's assume that B
succeeds and C fails what happens now
because we succeeded around box D so so
D goes tuned to the end cute State but
notice what happened to e FNG they all
failed so the key takeaway is that if a
unit of work fails then all descendant
work is also marked as failed if a unit
of work is
Hansol then all of its descendants are
also marked cancelled so I want to talk
about something called unique work and
let's start with a little question here
what's wrong with this code so you've
got an application object in the
oncreate you're in queueing some
periodic work the problem here and I've
seen this in a few bugs is that this in
queues periodic work every time your app
process starts and it's probably not
what you're trying to do you're trying
to do you're trying to set up a sink
here let's say it's you know syncing
your data every day if you if you call
this code every time the app starts
every time you've got another thing
that's syncing your code you really only
want one of them so unique work
basically is something that lets you
specify conflict policies for a database
insert think of it like that like if you
insert the same key into a database
again what do you want to happen do you
want to overwrite what's already in
there you want to ignore what you're
trying to do that's what unique work
does it basically is a conflict policy
for work manager and here's a syntax for
it it's pretty simple unique name is
that key it's that something that
uniquely identifies that chain of work
policy is the existing work policy or
what we call the conflict policies and
then you obviously have your requests so
the existing work policies are the
interesting things there's three of them
the first one is keep which is it keeps
the existing unfinished work so if you
have things that are in blocked running
or in queued it will keep them and if
something if the work is already
finished or it's not there to begin with
it'll in queue whatever you just sent
along with that call the next one is
replaced it always replaces the work
request in the database if your work is
running it'll get stopped as I described
a few minutes earlier it cancels the old
work and it stops it that's that's what
it does
append is kind of a special one it
basically appends to that chain of work
so for example this is useful if you're
trying to do something in order for
example you're trying to build a
messaging app and you're sending
messages in order so you may have a
unique
chain of work for sending messages and
you want to append new messages to the
end of it so it's basically creating a
tree for you remember so we mentioned
that in one of his previous slides on
because on how one can customize work
manager so let's look at how you all the
things that you can do so you can
actually specify a worker factory that
can be used to instantiate your workers
and listenable workers and this is
especially useful in the context of
dependency injection so if you're using
dagger and you want to inject something
into your worker before the worker
starts and this is a good place to do
that you can also specify the default
executor that you want that you want all
workers to use you can specify the
logging verbosity if you want you know
if you want distinguish between a build
and a release build and you want to make
sure you log more information to
diagnose your problems and then you can
also specify various other job scheduler
parameters like number of jobs that you
want us to send to job scheduler the IDS
of jobs that you want us to use in case
you're already using job scheduler
before so if you want to customize work
manager then you have to disable the
default work management initializer
first so for that you have to add this
entry to your manifest and note the
tools node remove that means you're
removing this you don't want this entry
to get merged so now that you've
disabled the default work manage
initializer the next step is to actually
create a new instance of configuration
so here I'm using the configuration
builder and I'm overriding it to specify
my own custom executor so now that I've
done that I can just call work manager
that initialize I specify the
application context and the
configuration and I'm done so make sure
you do this in your application on
create or a Content folder on create
because the system the operating system
can actually invoke job services on your
behalf and when you're when job services
are being invoked work manager needs to
be initialized finally the last thing we
want to talk about before we wrap up is
some tips for all the library developers
out there if you're using work manager
in your library you have some special
use cases that we want to think about so
the general advice we give
for library developers is because work
managers a singleton and the application
initializes it as Rahul just showed you
you are not really in control of what's
there
rely on the defaults so use the default
worker Factory the default worker
factory that we provide gives create
workers and listenable workers using
reflection rely on that because you
don't know what else is happening if
you're if you need some particular
dependency injection or anything else of
that sort you'll have to have a contract
with the app silo your work with tags so
Rahul also showed you how to tag your
work if you silo all your work meaning
you prefix or put your prefix or your
package name or your library name in
your tags you can easily identify all
the work that's your so you don't have
to worry about other people other
people's work you don't have to deal
with any of that you can just get your
work and operate on just that if you
don't know the IDS finally we do provide
the ability for apps to wipe away all
work and this is for generally for
privacy reasons this is not something we
expect to be called but it's for that
sort of critical use case where you have
to wipe user data for some reason so as
a library developer how do you find out
if your works been wiped or gone from
under you you should look at get last
get last cancel time sorry get last
cancel all time really it's a very
confusing name ok next steps so get work
manager if you haven't already and for
those of you who have thank you very
much your feedbacks been invaluable or
up to alpha 11 so there's three general
categories of artifacts here there's the
runtime there's the KTX stuff which
includes a coroutines worker that we
just put in so you don't have to write
your own and then there's testing
support as well these are some helpful
links scheduled tasks with work manager
is the developer.android.com section for
work manager there's a youtube on
youtube there's the google io 2018 talk
which talks about all the basics in much
greater length some of those aps have
changed a little bit but it's still
broadly a good thing to read or to
listen to and also please file your
feedback at
our public issue tracker beta is coming
we were told up this morning or last
morning as well so we're kind of we have
to get back to work but thanks a lot
please visit all the jetpack libraries
on the web and where it'll be outside
for any questions that you might have
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]